hey everyone this is Inka today I'm
filming a very very special episode for
you guys for this video I will be eating
only clear foods for 24 hours alright so
here we go this is the episode I'm
actually in Tokyo Japan right now that's
the beautiful Tokyo Tower so I know
after having done some research that
Japan actually has a lot of clear and
translucent food so I am going to sort
of include that under the umbrella of
clear foods today I don't want to just
be eating and drinking water all day I
am actually currently walking to the
supermarket I have a list of items that
I want but I'm also just going to check
out what they have at the store so
really hoping this works out candy I
think you can eat it just think this
never seen this before but this is like
almost like it's like clear sesame oil I
don't know what it is but this is clear
if you leave this daikon
[Music]
I'm at this place but I promise
Oh kuzumochi there's this kuzumochi that
is very clear I know they become
translucent uses salt candy I'm on my
way to the soy sauce specialty store
that my friends at tasty Japan told me
about I am super excited because
apparently they have over a hundred
types of soy sauce so can't wait to find
this amazing clear soy sauce
[Music]
so you get to sample it and I just tried
serving it tastes exactly like normal
soy sauce so I am shook morning everyone
so it is now day time here in Tokyo I am
definitely still jet-lagged you guys
know how normally I would eat foods for
breakfast there's a couple of fruits
that are kind of like clear and
translucent but apparently these types
of fruits are not that common here in
Tokyo I was not able to find any of them
so I'm afraid I won't be able to eat
fruit this time around I know it's not
the best way to start the challenge but
I am also a little bit sick so one cup
of water was what I was going to drink
anyways not my proudest moment I'm
really sorry breakfast today is a little
bit disappointing but we do have a lot
of really cool interesting things lined
up for the rest of the day now I'm going
to go back to packing some things up
I've got a bunch of videos to shoot at
the tasty studio space today so I'll see
you guys there I am ready and on my way
to work
thought I would treat myself because I
only have water this morning so I wanted
to try that usually salt candy I bought
here it is it's super clear I guess I'm
just curious because it says there's
salt in here too so oh yeah that's
really good you do actually taste the
specks of salt in there too I just got
like a pocket of one and I really like
it the salt probably helps bring the
sweetness out I don't think you can ever
really go wrong with handmade candy this
is exactly what I needed so I made it to
the office I got lost a couple times I
actually took the wrong train this
morning but I'm here at tasty Japan
getting ready to make a clear lunch I
don't really know how this is going to
go down at the supermarkets there was a
lot of things a lot more things than you
probably expected because I wasn't
expecting to find half as many things as
I did I think the biggest challenge here
is to make it into not just an edible
meal but like a tasty meal or a meal
that is really good let's just see what
we have to work with you have a lot of
stuff here we have rice wrappers we
probably see this the most when we're
eating I think
these cuisine leer soy sauce I'm super
excited to play with this some form of
substitute for sugar rice vinegar I was
trying to find white vinegar but this is
what they had in the tasty kitchen white
sesame oil that I've never seen usually
sesame oil is a dark brown I would say
pickled daikon because they've been
pickled they are much more translucent
mung bean vermicelli I think I grew up
eating this a quite a bit two types of
sashimi I don't know what kind of fish
they are so we're gonna ask a red to
help ma die there isn't like a specific
way to eat it with soy sauce and wasabi
I can work with that maybe thank you I
don't think I've even ever seen this
before
super translucent you can almost see
through it I'm not gonna be able to use
the tuna in the middle because it's not
clear I think what I'm gonna do is kind
of cook the noodles cut up the daikon
marinate the sashimi a little bit and
wrap them up with this we have a bunch
of sauces so I think I can play around
with that a little bit and we can take
it from there
sweet savory sour umami maybe try to
make a sauce using these different
condiments starting with this clear soy
sauce I feel like if you covered this up
and I didn't know what color it was I
would have totally thought it was just
normal
soy sauce because it's clear I think I
like forget that it's actually really
salty vinegar this doesn't smell like
anything right now but oh it tastes just
like simple syrup so I think we're on
the right track sugar sesame oil this is
just a clear sauce and tasted a little
bit feel like it's a little on the
sweeter side so I'm gonna add a little
bit more soy and a little more sesame
oil yeah I think that works now that I
have this marinade I can try to marinate
them this just looks like as much as I
want there to be wasabi we can't use it
because it's green you guys see that
this is the fish oh wow
they these are all safe to eat raw and
that's why we're doing this put these in
there are to believe that this is in
water I'm gonna set that aside this is
what the vermicelli looks like it's
actually translucent and not white gonna
go ahead and toss that in can't even
really see the noodles in there because
it's so clear but are the noodles
just going in to rinse the noodles
really quick I think I've got most of
the things prepped it's time to do some
wrapping this is what they look like
it's literally just a clear sheet if you
wanted to pixelate your face this is one
way to do it right now it's kind of hard
so all you have to do is put it in warm
water just a few seconds so you see how
it goes in I think that's good and now
it's even clearer than before a lot
floppier too so I'm gonna set that down
here it's also a lot stickier now I'm
going to sauce this a little bit I think
just with some soy sauce and sesame oil
[Music]
now to put some of these adds a little
bit of daikon just for extra flavor and
texture
oh hey this is our first rap it looks
really cool I don't like the cocoon of
sorts gonna make a couple more of these
and then let's serve it up this is it
these are our clear spring rolls you can
see the vermicelli the fish I will say
that it's a little more opaque now
there's a lot of things here that aren't
completely like transparent they clear
in a more translucent type of way and
when you put all those elements together
I think I guess they do appear a little
more white on camera I just have some
soda water this is our clear meal I'm
just gonna go right in for it really
don't know what it expects mm-hmm
there's a lot of flavors going on I have
to say I think the marinade actually
worked out pretty well
and because the daikon is pickled the
sweetness really adds a lot to it but
I'm really confused so I'm gonna try
that again now you can see the inside
probably just looks like really bland
food in a way I almost say it would be a
very healthy way to have a meal
considering what it looks like and what
it tastes like I think you would be
pleasantly surprised this is gonna be
pretty quick for me to finish but I
actually also have a dessert for this
meal I know usually it comes after
dinner but I think I actually found
enough things so I am going to bring in
dessert after I finish this up really
quickly I was really looking forward to
this this is called the kuzumochi so
this is actually a super popular
traditional snack in Japan like you know
how mochi is typically made of rice this
one's made out of Kazuko which is
another type of starch mochi is usually
white this one is actually more of a
translucent color this is
served with soybean powder and the type
of sweet syrup but in my case today you
will not be using these for obvious
reasons
in its place I have actually bought this
syrup I'm gonna scoop a bite out so you
guys can see satisfying who's kind of
the texture we're looking at it's very
jiggly you can see the spoon through
this I'm gonna take a bite without
putting syrup first mmm
it's already a little bit sweet oh it
almost looks like a raindrop cake it's
so jelly like I feel like I might have
had it before because I've never
actually eaten it as is so this is super
cool really treating myself here today I
have a lot to wear my mom here so I'm
going to wrap this up really quickly and
then get back to work so I am taking a
small break from work to actually work
on the raindrop cake that I want to have
for dinner I think it takes some time to
set in the fridge so gonna prepare it
now and then hopefully be able to bring
it home oh but before that I wanted to
try a candy this is Mel toast candy
don't have you guys too seen this before
last time I saw it actually was when I
was doing um dragon beards candy I'll be
eating it as is just like this little
guy here think I need a toothpick maybe
this trouble is real oh it's so sticky
it's not always this clear this is super
clear I've seen as being served on
streets before whoa
the perfect glove she grew up I'm just
playing with my food again oh there you
go look at that you want this so sweet
yeah my show you this is like what kids
eat miss Deveau over something it's so
good but it's also so much sugar
now that snack time is over and now that
I have sugar in my hair and can take it
back to the rain drop cake I'm just
using the recipe from tasty Japan I'm
gonna link you guys to the recipe I'm
using in the description box below this
is actually the same pot that used in
the video so I can't go wrong
that's done
you know work a little bit more now
alright guys so change of plans I know I
said I was gonna go home but it's
already dark out it gets dark really
early here it's like already past dinner
time and I'm really hungry so I'm just
gonna make dinner here since I have all
the ingredients with me anyways I was
thinking of making something fairly
quick I also consulted with read
beforehand to make sure I wasn't doing
anything too bizarre with the
ingredients here condiments aside we
really only have three things these
cooked bean sprouts bean sprouts
normally aren't that translucent but
after you cook them they become pretty
see-through over here we have what they
call toque little tin I really hope I am
saying that right this is again one of
those things that is very common here in
Japan it is actually made from seaweed
or LG and then we have these little baby
fishies called cheetah soup it actually
says right here that it's meant to be
consumed raw so that is also super
interesting I actually think I have this
yesterday at a restaurant you guys
recognize the sugar substitute from
earlier and the clear soy sauce sake and
meeting they're both just like pretty
common cooking line I'm probably gonna
combine all this to make a sauce let's
make this work you have the clear soy
sauce first meeting sake sure normally I
can kind of see how much I want based on
like the color of the mixture because
everything is clear is kind of trippy
just add a little bit of a taste it's
really hard to know how much that of
anything when it just look at how clear
that looks it's like I'm just boiling
water hanging this to the stovetop
reduce it a little bit you know I'm
gonna chop this up there's a lot of
water in this so I'm gonna pour that out
oh it's so clear actually already a
noodle forum I couldn't even tell from
the packaging whoa this is so
interesting Wow hmm I don't really think
it smells like anything but the texture
of its like a little softer than gelatin
doesn't taste like gelatin though it's a
clear fish not insane seafood they
actually start help translucent it's
just that after we cook it it comes okay
this is what we have this might look a
little bit terrifying cuz you can
actually see the little fishies but I
also grew up eating like little fishies
like this with rice usually it's cooked
I've never had them raw like this I'm
excited to try it the last thing to do
really is just to drizzle on the sauce
that I made I'm just gonna cool it and
then pour it over this I am now ready
for dinner
I haven't added a sauce yet this is it
let the sauce end up looking like it's
still very much clear can you guys still
see me through it there you have it it's
a clear full of noodles and fish
vegetables it turned out pretty clear I
bet when this video first started you
guys had no idea what to expect this is
probably the last thing you had in mind
this is wild oh also here it is
I've heard of clear Cola here but I
didn't actually expect to find it I
really want to start this meal off by
drinking this yeah it even smells like
coca-cola it kind of tastes a little bit
more like Cola candy cool a tasting
products it tastes like that this is
crazy
alright so now for the main course
apparently there are many ways to enjoy
this the packaging actually came with a
sweet sauce but you can eat a sweet or
savory let's try this the sauce turned
out really good and the little fishies
are like little pockets of umami
sprinkled through I actually really
liked the fish well people who are not a
fan of like a more slimy air texture you
probably wouldn't like it but it's like
sashimi and then the bean sprouts are
nice crunch I think the sauce I made was
a variation of teriyaki you wouldn't
expect to see teriyaki in this color
this is still the coolest thing ever
so I'm gonna slowly work on this and
then we can finally get to dessert this
is it this is the moment of truth
I was able to do it shall we you just I
wasn't even able to slowly do it but
here it is oh my god
I did it it's so beautiful Wow I have
never made a raindrop cake before I know
it's just water and sugar and there's no
reason to freak out but so excited to
eat it I have my syrup from earlier
[Music]
super excited I'm gonna dig right in you
guys Wow the flavor really is just over
sugar and water but the texture is so
pleasing I know this sounds crazy but
you can feel how jiggly it is as you're
eating it mmm
this is so great this was the best thing
to end on it's super refreshing I feel
like I'm getting at least two cups of my
eight cups of water per day so I
actually made to arrange our cakes for
safety and this one turned out even more
amazing this challenge honestly I
thought it would be pretty much
impossible I thought I'd be drinking
water that's it I can't stop eating this
I'm sorry I should stop I think as I was
shopping around here I found so many
more things than I thought there would
be I kind of blew my mind a little bit
it's always so amazing to see the
different kinds of food from different
cultures and like how when you're in
different places there's just so many
more things to discover this challenge
was actually pretty insightful it gave
me this opportunity to try out different
things like things maybe outside of my
comfort zone maybe things that I've
never even thought of trying before and
felt like I learnt a lot from it I hope
you guys did too now that I finally done
clear foods let me know what else I
should be doing whether it's a different
color maybe a different challenge I'm
open to any ideas you might have so let
me know until then see you guys
by
[Music]